- Let's get to my first guest y'all.
Like Virginia and Irving,
He is also from Iowa.
He's a producer, investor, and actor
who you know from That 70's Show,
Two and a Half Men, and the classic film
Dude, Where's My Car?
His new Netflix rom-com is
called Your Place Or Mine.
Please welcome, actually Virginia,
I think it might be cool if you call him,
you wanna do the honors?
- [Virginia] Yeah.
- Okay go for it
- (exaggerated yelling) Ashton!
(Kelly laughing)
(jazzy upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
(music stops)
(audience cheering)
- Have you...
Does Mila have like a sound she makes?
- Yes. I really, I wanted
her to change it to this one.
Ashton!
(kelly laughs) I really, I like that one.
Mila's is more like, Baby! Baby!
- [Kelly] (laughing)
just aggressive - Baby!
- [Kelly] I love it. - It's
just, that's what it is.
- [Kelly] Eventually,
does it take the three
to get your attention?
- Usually it's,
I'm really hard of hearing.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah?
- I can't hear that well,
and so it genuinely takes like a yell,
like to find me in the
house. - [Kelly] Got it,
You're going to fit right in on this show
Because I'm loud, so it's,
- [Ashton] I like it.
- So you're gonna hear everything I say.
- I love it. - [Kelly] (laughing)
Mila was here a few months ago,
and talked about the first time
that Ashton said he loved her.
And I think it's incredible,
so I wanna show you. (Ashton laughing)
- It happened to me and
it happened to my mother.
(laughing)
So my dad told my mom
he was in love with her
three months into their
relationship, shmammered,
fully shmammered, and my mom went,
all right talk to me in the
morning. - [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like, we'll reconvene
this. - [Kelly] Yeah.
- Same thing happened
to me with my husband.
Three months into our relationship
he like showed up in my house
at two o'clock in the morning,
and he was like, (slurring)
I love you so much.
And I was like, oh lord have,
I was like, go to bed. And he
goes, no, I love you so much.
And I was like, okay -
[Kelly] Super great, go home.
- [Mila] (laughing) Yeah.
(audience cheering)
- So - [Ashton] Okay.
- So, what's happening?
- Okay.
- [Kelly] What do you
remember about the night?
- The, oh, I remember it.
I'll give details. - [Kelly] Okay.
- I remember it distinctly,
because I came into her house,
and I was singing this Kenny Chesney song,
and I was like,
♪ you and tequila make me crazy ♪
(Kelly laughing)
Because there had been a little
too much tequila consumed,
and they both make me crazy.
And then I told her that I love her,
and I meant it when I
said it. - [Kelly] Yeah.
- And she was like, you you just tell me,
say that in the morning. And
then before, I woke her up,
and I was like, hey...
I love you.
And that's how I woke
her up in the morning.
I remember distinctly.
I don't know how I remember,
because I was really drunk, but...
- [Kelly] Sometimes though it is,
it takes a little liquid courage
to let the old walls down
- A little juice. - Yeah,
just a little bit of tequila.
What did you get Mila for Valentine's Day?
Do y'all exchange gifts still?
- It's tonight.
- I know, I know, but but she won't,
she doesn't watch. (laughs) -
[Ashton] I am not, I am not,
no, no, I'm not risking
it. I've done this before.
- I feel like she might like meaningful.
I feel like, what do you get each other?
You've been together so long.
- She's like a really,
okay, see here's the thing.
She's like a really...
she's a very specific gift giver.
Like, it's not about like what
something is, how big it is.
It's like, not about the
show, it's about like,
does it have meaning?
- Absolutely.
- Example. So for Christmas,
like her best friend and her manager,
they used to always have
this emergency place
that they would go to if
there was ever an emergency.
And it was in front of
Lucille Ball's house.
Like right in Beverly Hills.
(Kelly laughing) Like if
there was an emergency,
let's meet in front of
Lucille Ball's house.
That was the thing.
- This is the actual
incredible part of the story,
by the way. (laughing) Like what.
- So, but okay, so here's the thing,
So we drive by this house every day
on the way to take our kids
to school. - [Kelly] Yeah.
- And she's like, and one day we drive by
and they're tearing the house down.
And we're like oh my god,
they're tearing down Lucille Ball's house.
Like we, and she's like,
I need to (stuttering)
For Christmas, I need
to get them the bricks
from Lucille Ball's house
because they're tearing it down.
- Aw that's sweet. - And
I'm thinking to myself like,
how are we gonna get the bricks from...
it's like a construction
site, it's all fenced off.
So I sneak into the construction site,
and I steal like three bricks
from the construction site
- This is a good man. This is a good man.
- And I put them in the back of my truck,
and I go home I'm like, baby
I got something for you.
I got you the bricks.
And so, and she's like, oh my
god, you got me these bricks.
This is the most amazing
thing in the world.
So she packages them up and
puts them in these little boxes,
and puts a little tab, says
Lucille Ball's house on it,
And then gives them to her friends.
She gives it to her friend...
and we find out that wasn't
Lucille Ball's house,
that was the house across the street
from Lucille Ball's house!
(Kelly and audience laughing)
And so I stole some random bricks
from Eddie Cantor's house,
and I'm like, what is going on? Like I-
- Which makes it a way better story.
- Yeah, it does, so then
she changed the plaque
and it says not Lucille
Ball's house on it.
But those are the kind
of sentimental things.
So it's, it's very detail oriented.
- I think that's very
cool. I'm the same way.
I mean I feel like at this point
we can buy whatever we want,
it's like the meaningful
stuff that's cool.
- It's got to be meaningful. - Yeah.
- It's gotta have like some resonance.
- Even if you're the (chuckling)
it's intentional, but it's another house.
- Even if it's not Lucille Ball's house.
- Yeah, it's fine. I just love
that was their meeting place.
- That was the spot.
- That's gonna be a question
next time I talk to her.
So I wanted to ask you
Ashton how you're feeling.
Because I know you had
some autoimmune stuff going on, right?
- Yeah
- [Kelly] Because I have a
couple things going on like that.
- I had this thing like, it
was like three years ago.
I'm feeling great, like amazing.
But I had a thing like three years ago
that like knocked me on my butt
that was like this weird,
strange autoimmune, super rare
like only 300 people
have ever had this thing,
or been diagnosed. - What?
- It's called Susac's Syndrome.
And it was like this
weird, like my body decided
that the inside of my blood vessels
were not supposed to be there.
But they sorted it out,
and I've been great for three years so.
- Oh my gosh.
Well that's amazing, isn't it?
It's crazy the older we,
I'm 40 so we're close in age,
and it's like the older you get,
you (bleep) just starts happening
that you're like, what? - Yeah.
- Yeah, and it's just like,
you actually feel like,
okay this is what it's
like to be old. (laughing)
Or older, getting older.
- And when you get hurt, it doesn't heal.
- Not as fast.
- Like it's like a month. - Yeah.
- Or two months or a year. - I know.
- I got a thing from like eight months ago
that's still just like a thing.
- Dude, when I go to the
doctor, I'm just like
I know it's gonna be something.
It's like you know used to go
to the doctor for a checkup
like oh, doing great.
And then it's always just something random
that I've never heard of.
- I tried to serve a tennis ball.
- Oh.
- I just... like now
three years, this shoulder
it's just like, it's not coming back.
- It's just not cool.
- Yeah - Yeah - It happens.
- I heard that you're also
spending time as a Scout leader?
- [Ashton] Yeah.
- That's cool. I was a Girl Scout.
- Oh, I love it,
I was a Cub scout and
then I was a Boy Scout.
- [Kelly] Yeah. - I absolutely love it.
I love what it gave me, I love the whole-
- [Kelly] Me too. - I love
the skills that I got from it.
I love just that-
- Working as a team, yeah.
- Also in just the sense
of confidence of like,
if it all goes down,
I'll be able to figure
this thing out, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah. - And
so UCLA actually was,
I think it was like Troop
Number One originally.
It was like the very first Boy Scout troop
in the United States of America.
And they had disbanded the troop
because not enough kids
were participating.
And so like five parents got together
and were like let's
start back up the scouts.
And so we started up a Scouts
troop from zero this year.
And now we have like 40
scouts, boys and girls
because scouts is now
co-ed, which is amazing.
- Yeah.
- And our Pinewood Derby's coming up,
and we're gonna have to go for the win.
- Wait, Pinewood Derby, is
that when you do the car?
(audience clapping)
You build the cars?
- Yeah, they make the little
cars and then we race them.
- [Kelly] Yeah. - That's all.
- It's so cool that you do that.
And it's fun to do with your
kids I'm assuming as well.
- [Ashton] It's great.
I also find it very helpful
to be able to spy on who the
other kids in the school are.
- [Kelly] (laughing) Exactly.
- Like you really get to know like-
- No you can not have
a play date with him-
- No you're not hanging
out with Edwin today
because Edwin is busy. (Kelly laughing)
Like, you know the answer.
- He is on a family trip right now.
- He is on a, they're on a trip.
- That's 100% so true for
every parent watching.
Let's talk about your new movie.
So it's called Your Place or Mine.
So what is it about, who do you play?
- Okay, so Reese had reached
out with Aline Brosh McKenna
who made Devil Wears Prada and
27 Dresses. - [Kelly] Yeah.
- And they were making this thing,
they said do you wanna come do this?
And I was like, yes. Done. Yes.
- Yeah. - Like count me in, let's do it.
And it's about this
long distance friendship
where this couple, well
they're not a couple,
they're friends, best friends,
and they've been best
friends for like 20 years,
and not romantically engaged at all.
And they end up having to swap houses.
My character lives in New York,
Reese's character lives in Los Angeles.
- And they end up moving
across the country,
and in living in each other's lives,
they realize that they were
meant for each other all along.
- Yeah. - And, but it's
this kind of crazy movie
where the whole movie is over FaceTime.
It's us in different places.
We're only in three scenes
in the entire movie together.
- That's different!
- So it's really bizarre, really cool.
And it's, and it's really about like,
dealing with all your adult crap
in order to open yourself up
to what's right in front of you.
- Aw I love that tease!
That was a really good tease.